Speaker 1: Rarely a day is going by, certainly
not a week where we don't learn yet another
element of the absurdity and insanity and
in some cases, the criminality that allegedly
took place during the Trump administration,
you have been following the story.
If you've been watching the show, listening
to the show of Donald Trump taking classified
documents to Mar a Lago, flushing documents
incinerating documents.
No word yet on whether he smoked or sauteed
any, but that would be the next shoe to drop.
The National Archives have now confirmed and
turned over to the Justice Department that
Donald Trump did take classified items to
his house at Mar a Lago, and the projection
all along has just been stunning.
Remember, Hillary Clinton can't be trusted.
Her emails private email.
She would be irresponsible with sensitive
and classified documents.
Well, then Trump, during his presidency, goes
and spills secrets to a Russian spy recruiter,
Sergei Kislyak in the Oval Office.
Trump's family, like Ivanka and Jared Kushner
and others using private email for White House
business, Trump ripping up presidential records,
which people come in and tape back together.
Trump's sending documents in burn bags to
the Pentagon to be incinerated, which are
to be kept by the Presidential Records Act,
according to the Presidential Records Act.
Trump flushing documents down the toilet,
clogging it, having to call maintenance to
unclog the toilet.
And yes, he took classified documents to his
house.
National Archives.
AP report Trump took classified items to Mar
a Lago.
Classified information was found in the 15
boxes of White House records that were stored
at former President Donald Trump's Mar a Lago
residence, the National Archives said Friday
in a letter that confirms the matter has been
sent to the Justice Department.
That's called possible criminality.
The letter from the agency follows numerous
reports around Trump's handling of sensitive
and even classified information during his
time as president and after he left the White
House.
The revelation could also interest federal
investigators for policing the handling of
government secrets.
Though the Justice Department and FBI have
not indicated they will pursue federal law
bars, the removal of classified documents
to unauthorized locations, though it is possible
that Trump could try to argue that as president,
he was the ultimate declassification authority.
So there's a couple of different things here,
and some of you have written to me and said,
David.
The classified nature doesn't matter.
Only the violations of the Presidential Records
Act matter because Trump, as the president,
can declassify anything that's up for legal
dispute.
I spoke to a couple of lawyers who said, So
yes, Trump can declassify anything that he
wants.
However, he didn't declassify these things.
He just took them.
And there is this weird in-between situation
where there's the violation of the Presidential
Records Act.
There is an issue with him taking classified
documents, although he could declassify them.
But merely taking them doesn't, by definition,
declassify them.
It's a legal matter to sort out.
But looking backwards, everything Trump talked
about, others doing, he was doing.
He said, Hillary will do all of this stuff.
No, no, no.
You will do it.
And you did do it.
Remember the toilet rant?
We all saw it.
Why is Trump talking about toilets over and
over and over again?
He's obsessed with the fact that toilets aren't
flushing like they used to, and now maybe
we know.
Speaker 2: Remember this we have a situation
where we're looking very strongly at sinks
and showers and other elements of bathrooms
where you turn the faucet on in areas where
there's tremendous amounts of water, where
a man rushes out to sea because you could
never handle it and you don't get any water,
you turn on the faucet, you don't get any
water, they take a shower and water comes
dripping out is dripping out, very quietly
dripping out.
People are flushing toilets 10 times 15 times
as opposed to once they end up using more
water.
Speaker 1: Right?
Trump's complaints about good old toilets
just aren't flushing the way they used to.
For all we know, it was because he was trying
to flush documents down the toilet and it
was getting clogged and he was having to call
maintenance.
So this is this is all as bad as anything
he said anybody else was doing.
Consider also how, in the meantime, Fox News
has barely barely covered this story.
But they did mention Hillary Clinton like
a hundred times over the weekend on the basis
of the supposed Durham report, we're going
to get to that in a moment.
So at the end of the day, Trump could have
declassified these documents so that he would
not have been stealing classified documents
as the president.
He does have the ultimate authority to declassify.
There is this kind of weird in-between status.
He definitely violated the Presidential Records
Act that we know, and no one would believe
this if it weren't all completely true.
It's too absurd.
If you wrote a screenplay about a wacky president
and you included a scene of him flushing documents
down the toilet after accusing his opponent
of being untrustworthy with documents, it
would be like, You can't do it.
It's too.
It's too much.
It's too cliché.
It's too absurd.
No one would believe it.
No one would do it.
It is real life, folks.
It's real, real life.
And that's what's going on.